bonjour jean marc ravi de bons jeux vous
retrouvé ce matin dans la matinale
d'arreter france alors si la classe
politique ont la vue est partagé le
monde des professionnels est de plus en
plus favorable par contré et l'union
européenne prépare d'ailleurs le d pour
le début du mois de juin ce fameux
passeport sanitaire valable dans tous
les pays de l'union européenne
pourquoi des ses réticences en france
pourquoi ça marche pas ça marche pas
parce que je crois on est en france et
que l'administration n'a pas fait
beaucoup d'efforts de pédagogie et puis
nous sommes très prudents notamment au
niveau du gouvernement nous sommes ici
ont paralysé à l'idée de toucher à cette
liberté individuelle a dit je suis
convaincu qu'on disposera d'un passeport
australien perd parce que ce passeport
attestera que nous sommes sans danger
donc nous serons libres de 20 kg à nos
occupations les grandes entreprises
vous avez raison les professionnels du
spectacle les restaurateurs nous avons
vu tout à l'heure dans l'eau dans le
reportage et qui sont très réticents à
l'idée d'ouvrir dans des conditions qui
sont très restrictives
si on leur rentabilité ces restaurateurs
vont passer outre les réserves du
ministère de la santé
ils vont sans doute réclamé la
généralisation du pass sanitaire
d'ailleurs leurs clients le leur
demanderons c'est le seul moyen de
réinstaller un climat de confiance
alors je crois se passe sanitaire ne
sera sans doute jamais obligatoire en
france mais il sera indispensable pour
profiter d'une vie presque normale
affaire de bon sens partagé par le plus
grand nombre
l'opinion publique peut changer d'avis
elle va changer d'avis avec la
vaccination
vous vous souvenez il ya quelques temps
la majorité des français était assez
violemment opposé au principe même du
vaccin
eh bien vous voyez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui il se précipite désormais
pour recevoir les premières doses et
notamment les jeunes dont on pensait
qu'ils étaient indifférents à tout ça et
qui vont à la chasse au rendez vous là
sur les quelques applications qui gère
cette opération et qui s'avère
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus efficace que
l'administration publique de la santé je
pense à dr il ya quand même sauvé cette
campagne ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'à côté des centres installés par les
municipalités à côté des labos à côté
des hôpitaux et bien et même d'ailleurs
des pharmaciens qui sont entrés un peu
dans dans le jeu les grandes entreprises
sont se sont mises à à vacciner comme
d'ailleurs la position contre d'ailleurs
la position de la médecine du travail
qui traînait des pieds alors pour ces
entreprises là il s'agit de quoi il
s'agit de répondre à une demande de leur
personnel
qui dans le but de favoriser notamment
le retour au bureau ou dans les ateliers
aujourd'hui le travail est encore
quasiment obligatoire des travailleurs a
perdu d'inventer des nouvelles formes
d'organisation mais on sait très bien
qu'il va pas durer sept jours sur sept
beaucoup ont quand même envie de revenir
au boulot côté vaccination
les objectifs seront sans doute atteint
on peut penser qu'à l'été la moitié de
la france bénéficiera d'une immunité
collective et donc c'est la vaccination
qui va rendre ce passeport
incontournable évidemment absolument et
je crois qu'il aura même pas débat à
partir du moment où le monde aura la
possibilité de tout le monde aura la
possibilité de se faire vacciner
ce qui est quand même aujourd'hui
presque le cas pas tout à fait encore
parce qu'il ya comme des régions
compliqué mais les gens vaccinés
voudront être libres de circuler à leur
guise et en toute liberté
donc le projet de rendre obligatoire
cette sorte de passeport vert qui soit
digital sous forme de qr codes ou en
papier sous forme de certificats carnet
de vaccination bat ce projet-là a été
combattu pendant de longs mois par une
partie de l'opinion la classe politique
médiatique aussi tous ses opposants
considéré qu'il s'agissait d'une
atteinte insupportable à la liberté
individuelle allant même jusqu'à créer
des inégalités entre ceux qui auraient
un passeport et ce qu'il en aurait pas
en quelques semaines le vent a tourné
la cnil le gendarme qui veillent
scrupuleusement aux libertés
individuelles à amender d'ailleurs son
diagnostic est ce que le parlement après
beaucoup de tergiversations politicienne
on a quand même autorisé le principe à
quoi qu'ils disent et surtout l'union
européenne c'est thierry breton le
commissaire européen qui en a pris
l'initiative a annoncé que la commission
sortirait un modèle de passe sanitaire
valable dans l'union européenne tout
entière
résultat depuis quelques jours
l'application tous antico vide dont
certains d'entre nous ont déjà
téléchargé le système qui avait été
lancée au départ dans un état de
méfiance 1 au début de la pandémie
elle a pas beaucoup de succès à l'acte
est mise à jour pour intégrer des plats
sanitaire date de vaccination dalle de
vaccins différents tests effectués la
liste de des anticorps pour ceux qui ont
été malades du cobp et hop un simple qr
codes toutes ces informations se
traduisent sur le smartphone est
l'application peut être téléchargée en
donnant son numéro de sécurité sociale
c'est très rap et en quelques jours
d'ailleurs beaucoup de français
se sont aperçus que cette présentation
était beaucoup plus opérationnel
beaucoup plus commode que toutes les
attestations pas fier qu'on nous inflige
vrai qu'on nous inflige est déjà pendant
le conflit
on va dire elle reste une frange de la
population jean marc qui est encore
opposé à toute forme de contrôle
bayrou est par principe peut-être par
idéologie un bien sûr mais cette france
va se réduire quand on va s'apercevoir
que ce passeport est obligatoire pour
voyager pour partir en vacances et les
vacances c'est pour bientôt
allez dans un stade un concert la
contrainte du pass sanitaire va paraître
complètement dérisoire on pourra
toujours refusé de se faire vacciner ou
de se faire tester merlas en
connaissance de cause se passe sanitaire
sera opérationnel à l'échelle européenne
début juin une sorte de permis de vivre
ensemble
simple comme le permis de conduire il
est quand même obligatoire alors bien
sûr on peut conduire sans permis mais il
ya ces représente quand même un certain
nombre de risques
alors pour l'instant le gouvernement est
prudent latine il a précisé qu'à partir
du 9 juin
les réunions de plus de mille personnes
seront accessibles sur présentation d'un
test négatif et ou d'un certificat de
vaccination alors ça n'est pas son nom
mais c'est vraiment à part cela ni terre
ce qui va concerner les chapiteaux les
théâtres et salles des
foires-expositions les stades les
casinos les festivals les compétitions
sportives des cinémas les restaurants a
priori est pour l'instant l'acte il
n'autorise pas les usages du passé
l'inter à l'entrée des grands magasins à
l'entrée des lieux d'enseignement les
bibliothèques des cinémas les grands
magasins jul vise à décamper
mais il est vrai qu emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs avait rappelé sa volonté de
ne pas introduire de discrimination dans
la vie quotidienne et on voit bien que
l'administration se perdent dans la
complexité bureaucratique quand il
s'agit de définir les lieux les
activités qui nécessiteront le pass
sanitaires dans les zones c'est la
journée aujourd'hui va quand même être
très désordre on saura pas là où on peut
aller exactement et et combien de
personnes la vérité que la vérité c'est
que là encore c'est une question de bon
sens quand il y aura 50 millions
d'habitants qui seront protégés et on
peut espérer qu'en septembre octobre ce
sera fait passer habitons la
n'accepteront pas d'être privé de
liberté pourquoi mettre à quelques-uns
de vivre sans être vaccinés c'est à dire
de porter le risque de faire repartir la
pandémie merci beaucoup
jean-marc pour ses explications est très
clair jean marc silva s'était l'édito
échos de la matinale